hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of The Walking Dead Season eight episode
7 time for after and I think it's time
for us to finally ask ourselves which
fan favorite character is more of a
totally unnecessary threat for Rick
smartest man and the zombie apocalypse
Eugene or shoot first and ask questions
never Daryl or is it Rick for repeatedly
trusting people who spend their free
time sculpting nudes from garbage as
always I'm gonna break down all the
interesting stuff I noticed this episode
some connections to the past episodes
and stuff in the comics and parallels to
history and possible explanations for
where things are headed next week's
mid-season finale so let's once again
start with the big question brought to
us by Jacqueline on Twitter yeah what
was going on with Eugene and his final
scene there like why was he throwing up
that wine was he poisoned okay
let's break down the different options
here that wine was given to him as
payment by Tanja for Eugene fixing her
stereo remember Tanja was one of
Meegan's wives from last season who
asked Eugene to make poison supposedly
for the tormented wife amber to kill
herself
Eugene later realizes they just wanted
that poison pill to poison Meighan now I
don't think Tanya poisoned this wine or
anything it was clearly sealed when she
handed it to him and remember she
doesn't have poison that's why she
needed Eugene in the first place I also
don't think Eugene found a spare poison
pill or anything in Sasha's casket
Sasha took the pill that Eugene gave her
it's why she came out of it as a walker
and lunged a vegan and I definitely
don't think Eugene seemed suicidal at
all here another option is that Eugene
could have been infected by Gabriel
there was that shot of his finger with a
dab of sick Gabriel's blood on it
ultimately I think that blood shot is
connected to Eugene state of mind at the
end but on a symbolic level to me this
shot suggests that Eugene has blood on
his hands he feels extreme guilt for
Sasha's death and for the death he's
about to bring his old friends by
helping Meighan at the same time the
horror of seeing the walkers attacking
Savior workers rattled him so much that
he keeps Dwight's treason a secret
negan else have another person's blood
on his hands so all this pressure
tortures Eugene so much that he has to
drown himself in wine just to get some
sleep but he's too queasy to keep
anything down and the vomiting seems
more like a symptom of his sickness of
his soul than any sickness of his body
now I know you guys have more questions
and I'll get to them as I go through the
other stuff I noticed starting with some
parallels to past episodes in our
segment callbacks okay right at the top
of the episode I was interested to see
Jadis using this old timey flashbulb
camera to take pictures of Rick now I
suppose she wanted a photograph of
Rick's body to sculpt from and this
other guy's sketches wouldn't have been
like like enough whatever now I know we
keep pointing this out but people keep
snapping photos of each other throughout
the season it's kind of a recurring
thing and this one is kind of a
reflection of Rick previously taking
Polaroids of the Savior's as proof of
their retreat for Jada's to see now it's
worth reminding ourselves that it's a
big deal to take photographs in this
zombie apocalypse electricity is limited
so smartphones and digital cameras and
computers are luxuries that most people
don't really bother with even more
traditional cameras like the Polaroid
and Jada's camera here require film and
bulbs that must be super hard to come by
and nearly impossible to develop unless
jatis is like a Red Room in one of those
shipping containers so the rarity of
photographs in this new world should
strike our curiosity it's almost as if
by taking these photos these characters
are dehumanizing each other transforming
them from living breathing threats into
still lifeless subjects there's that old
superstition from native tribes around
the world that cameras steal the
subjects soul and before you ask no the
Amish community doesn't believe that
their objection to cameras is related to
their avoidance of modern technology in
general and a biblical belief against
graven images and vanity I don't know
why I'm defending the Amish it's not
like they were watching this or you
shouldn't be watching this unless you're
on your crime spree on or whatever it is
anyway
I think there is something to this soul
stealing in this uncivilized world the
Savior's took Polaroids of negan's
victims essentially stealing their souls
they now remembered as these mutilated
faceless corpses Rick kind of stole
negan's soul by taking a Polaroid of him
and defeat maybe the only image of this
man looking less than almighty and now
Jadis is trying to steal Rick's soul
stripping him down
turning him into a statue in her
collection okay later when Dwight tries
to turn Eugene he reminds him of negan's
barbarism this screams the smell of
burning skin Dwight is calling back mark
from last season whom negan burned with
an iron to the face just like Dwight was
in the past and if you look closely the
immediate next scene shows us mark he
passes the camera and you can see the
burn scars on his face and then when he
passes Eugene Eugene doesn't react at
all he just keeps staring at the threat
of the walkers outside showing us how
early on Eugene is still completely
unsympathetic to negan sadism it's still
about survival for him later when Eugene
raids Sasha's coffin for his iPod
remember Eugene gave Sasha this iPod
along with that poison pill in her final
moments in last season's finale and it's
worth pointing out that the most recent
song on that iPod was Donny Hathaway's
someday we'll all be free it was an
interesting song choice for Sasha a
tortured captive longing to free herself
from this world and now that song kind
of applies to Eugene state of mind as
well a captive who's longing to be free
in his own way of thinking Eugene says
to Dwight a chomp down on your Chow wood
and Dwight looks down yeah that was a
callback to season 6 when Eugene bit
Twite on the dick to escape capture and
we got a few callbacks to Rick's first
encounter with the scavengers in season
7 Jada's forces rick to fight this
walker whether it has a helmet on looks
like a round two version of Winslow from
last season maybe like Winslow jr. Rick
and jatis also repeat to their Hagelin
game in previous bargains it ended with
Rick taking a bad deal being forced to
say yes and now it ends with Jada
settling with Rick's initial offer jatis
also makes a callback to wanting to lay
with Rick something she brought up in
last season's finale he or she wants to
sculpt him like one of her French girls
but oh yeah Rick's not having it okay
let's move on to some of the cultural
and historical influences on this
episode and our segment under the
influence okay
early in the episode Rick tells Jadis
quote you can join us or you can die now
this reminded me a lot of the famous
join or Die political cartoon by
Benjamin Franklin which was used as
propaganda to unite the American
colonies in the years leading up
the American Revolutionary War now this
one detail kind of sent me into a
tailspin of historical parallels this
episode last season I compared Rick's
war effort to that of the American
Continental Army and now I think Rick's
struggles and a lot of these characters
have interesting historical counterparts
in that time period let's start with
Rick now Rick is kind of the George
Washington figure the commander-in-chief
of the Continental Congress
forging precarious alliances to fight a
war of attrition to gain independence
from a tyrant
Rick's alliance with the scavengers who
are large a number and unfamiliar in
their language and culture reflects the
Americans alliance with the French a
rival power who spoke a different
language but was totally necessary for
victory
later Washington would have to temper
his friendship with a French blocking
them from enlisting American militia in
their own revolution and refusing to
pick a side in their war with England
suggesting Rick's alliance with the
scavengers here may also be based on
short-term opportunism Washington also
had rivals to his authority from within
his ranks chief among them was general
Horatio Gates who wanted to slice a
victory at Saratoga convincing the
French to support the Americans
Washington was frustrated by gates
ambition to ask him as
commander-in-chief and I think the
closest parallel to Gates is Daryl like
gates with Washington Daryl was has
butted heads with his commander to find
him with a more rushed war strategy that
defiance led Daryl to end the savior's
blockade around them in sanctuary and
sworn the sanctuary with walkers
throwing a wrench into Rick's alliance
with the scavengers now I get it guys we
all love Daryl but this unilateral
charge was selfish stupid and
strategically catastrophic historically
it echoes gates in the Battle of Camden
one of the most humiliating defeats for
the Americans during the Revolutionary
War he took a direct route into British
territory feeling cocky after those
recent wins at Saratoga but gates forces
were ultimately devastated leaving gates
fleeing 180 miles on horseback and being
labeled a coward for the rest of his
life now I think the parallels with
Darrell in there I don't see Daryl being
a deserter
but his aggression and his disrespect to
Rick Washington makes him very gates ian
in my eyes we can also apply this
historical parallel to the men behind
enemy lines Dwight as a spy for Rick and
parallels figures like Hercules Mulligan
up in there love anew yes he heard your
mother say come again
it's a Hamilton reference whistles in
the soundtrack it's great Hercules
Mulligan was one of Washington's many
spies within the British ranks he worked
as a tailor for British officers and he
passed along information that he
overheard about their movements that
ultimately saved Washington's life at
one point Dwight has done similar
espionage of course to help Rick and
Darryl has saved their asses many times
and that leaves Eugene the true Benedict
Arnold of this war now Arnold was the
American general who secretly plotted
against Washington and then defected and
joined the British he's considered one
of the greatest traitors in American
history however Eugene's ingenuity
actually seems largely inspired by some
someone else the founding father that I
opened this whole line of thinking for
me Benjamin Franklin like Franklin
Eugene is remarkably gifted as an
engineer who comes up with clever
practical solutions to problems we even
see Jean doing a kind of kite experiment
in this episode like how Franklin can
you get now during this experiment
Eugene describes this advise a
remote-control glider strapped with an
amplified ipod to lead away the Walker
horde and uses a term Pied Piper
okay Pied Pipers a common term
referencing the German legend of the
Pied Piper of Hamelin where a piper
wearing colorful clothes was hired by a
town to play his magical pipe and lure
the rats out of the town but when the
citizens refused to pay him for his
service he uses the same magical pipe to
lure away their children yes German
folklore is super creepy okay we could
see a similar thing happening with
Eugene right like maybe when his
services to lure away these Walker rats
go unrewarded by negan Eugene will use
his abilities to turn on him that's
right Eugene Porter a genius oddball
with a head full of great ideas to help
your community who will come for your
children if you were on him moving on
there are a few interesting details and
the visual assets of this episode so
let's look closely at some of these
shots with our segment zoom in' enhance
okay first check out this shot of eugene
sitting beside gabriel in his medical
bed and the light that pours in through
the window here has this angelic quality
that gives gabriel who by the ways named
after the angel gabriel some divine
already in the scene it's interesting
how Gabriel challenges Eugene as a man
of science to explain the dead rising as
anything other than a miracle proof of a
higher power and the limitations of
science now it's not common for this
show to depict these zombie apocalypse
is a good thing but remember
resurrection is a totally different
meaning to a man of faith like Gabriel
the New Testament Jesus resurrected
Lazarus he resurrected himself and the
dead rising again is also a sign for the
book of Revelation of the end of the
world but nevertheless Gabriel can use
resurrection as evidence that his
faith-based life means something another
detail I like notice how Eugene talks
through his experiment and he records
himself on tape and they make sure to
include this close-up of the tape
recorder as Eugene flings it around his
side and notice how we never see Eugene
turn off the record switch when Dwight
drops in on him it's possible that this
entire conversation with Dwight in which
Dwight confessed quote I'm working with
them and quote we can get rid of negan
could have been recorded on tape now of
course it sounds like Eugene wasn't
ready to rat out Dwight to negan but
this tape could end up blowing Dwight's
entire operation wide open whether or
not Eugene chooses to do it
intentionally the last visual detail
pertains to something that happens way
later in the comics and if you haven't
read the comics and you don't want to
know and you don't wanna get spoiled
don't worry just skip to this time
alright cool all good
ok at the end of the episode rick
stumbles upon the corpse of a guy who
had stumbled down a lookout ladder who's
now hanging by his feet as Walker's feed
on him this is similar to how a major
character dies in the comics long after
the war with the Savior's now I don't
need to tell you who exactly you can
actually look it up if you want I'm just
interested in the dets themselves being
similar now there have been other
moments this season that seem like
possible nods to memorable comic deaths
heads on spikes gallows and I'm
wondering if the writers are slipping
these in just for us comic readers to
tease what's to come we will see now
before I move on to the deeper meaning
this episode one of my favorite
questions I got on Twitter came from
bacon man do walkers poop and then
Jeremiah requested to answer this in
theory time so you know what sure I am
fascinated by this subject so let's
theory time the [ __ ] out of this
question yeah pun intended
so the question of the walkers biology
and digestion
Cole has come up before with whether or
not today poop ranking near the top of
all zombie related search queries
Grantland actually published a really
good article answering this very
question and you should definitely read
it but to summarize there are a few ways
to look at this according to the Zombie
Survival Guide complete protection from
the Living Dead zombies do not digest
human flesh like their stomachs and
their intestines don't extract nutrients
and then excrete waste the way living
humans do instead the rotting human meat
according to this book just gradually
builds up inside of them until the
zombies explode in which case maybe some
of that flesh comes out of their booty
hole gross however more scientific
analyses have pointed out that the
zombie virus likely only affects areas
of the brain that do not control
digestion which instead is controlled by
the enteric nervous system throughout
the body so theoretically if the
Walker's are capable of walking and
clawing and biting they're also capable
of digesting and pooping we also saw
Eric and Darrell open up a Walker's
belly in season 2 and searched for
Sofia's remains so it's safe to assume
that in The Walking Dead universe at
least these walkers do process food the
way living bodies do in which case to
answer your question bacon man yes these
walkers are probably constantly [ __ ]
themselves get a whiff of that
okay let's grow up here and move on to
the deeper meaning of this episode
titled time for after now it's a
reference to Jay toises threatening
words to Rick essentially answering the
question that he had earlier this
episode of what is after in this episode
after is defined as when the [ __ ] hits
the fan
god I really can't shake off [ __ ] thanks
a lot big man after is the price that
you pay when you're careful scheming
blows up in your face so for Rick his
scheme is to reappropriation his face
this also applies to Eugene this episode
Eugene is a meticulous schemer he
devised security measures for the
sanctuary he sussed out
white is a spy he engineered a new
aerial fat lady and he apparently came
up with a new escape solution that we
haven't seen yet
but his after is the emotional toll that
this scheming takes on his soul as he
watches more and more people go to use
his word and horizontal for it Eugene
Rick and all these characters a time
comes when you pay this toll and this
episode begins that time for after okay
let's check in on this week's kill count
although Rick showed off some pretty
heroic scrambling to turn the tables on
the scavengers the deadliest this
episode was Darrell who took out at
least a dozen walkers when he mowed them
down with the truck and another
countless number of Savior workers when
those walkers spread into the sanctuary
so let's put his kill count at 20 at
least in this season we're seeing how
those higher numbers don't necessarily
make a character productive in this case
those 20 plus deaths actually did more
to undo Rick's overall strategy never
thought I would side with characters who
back away from conflict like Rosita
Michonne did this episode but they
proved themselves to be far more
sensible so a question for you guys do
you think Daryl deserves to be ousted or
sidelined after this strategic blunder
and let's make some death predictions
before next week's mid-season finale
which character do you think is most
likely to die of this group
let's see Morgan Dwight Eugene Gabriel
or Gregory I'm calling it now if it's a
major character death that we're looking
at I think we'll know who it is if the
episode establishes an introspective arc
for that character in the opening
minutes just a member last season when
Spencer and Sasha got lots of screen
time at the tops of their final episodes
we knew they weren't going to survive
those hours comment down below with your
thoughts or tweet me directly at he a
vas you can also follow new rock stars
on Twitter at new rock stars for updates
on their videos and like and share this
video and subscribe to new rock stars
for all of our deep dives into season 8
of the walking dead including breakdowns
of the previous six episodes that you
should definitely check out and if you
really want to help this channel grow
and expand and cover more things that
you love you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our donors
especially Kenny Smith thanks for
watching guys see you next week bye